alright guys this video is going to be
the first in a series of videos about
the fundamentals of kicking technique so
a lot of people ask me how I have
developed my kicks to such a level where
they're very clean and crisp looking as
well as quick and explosive and from
what I've observed it's not so much
about people's drills that they're do
and it's more the concepts underneath
that they're not really aware of so
that's why I wanted to do this series
the reason I'm recording in this
building today is to make a point about
that if you check this building out
obviously everything's gone from it it's
been basically gutted there's no paper
on the walls there's no carpets there's
no heating or electricity however the
basic shell the foundations are still
standing nice and strong and probably
will continue to do for a number of
years and that's the same principle that
we want to focus on with martial arts
training I'm sure you've heard the
analogy that if you build a house upon
shaky foundations no matter how much
money you've got to build that house you
could have a billion dollars then the
slightest gust of wind is just gonna
blow it straight over even many
instructors can only really explain to
their students the differences between
techniques so they might explain the
difference between a front kick and a
turning kick for example but that's a
far cry away from really truly
understanding the subtle nuances they go
into refining a technique over time to a
point where it's then masterfully
executed if I could explain in one
single example of how that's achieved is
by focusing on the small things and by
small things I mean the things that most
people kind of view is arbitrary
[Music]
because we know when we add up all those
inches that's gonna make the [ __ ]
difference between the reason that most
casual martial artists quit training is
because they lose interest with
repeating the same things over and over
again their lessons
most people are obsessed with the idea
of finding advanced tactics quick fixes
everything that needs to be advanced
advanced but the truth is advanced
tactics will only give you incremental
improvements compared to mastery of the
basics in anything if you look at
cause-and-effect the basics probably
count for 80 to 90 percent of your
improvement while any advanced tactics
probably 10 or 20 percent not only that
they're much harder to learn as well so
if you're not getting the results you
want I can assure you that the answer is
not hiding in advanced tactics it's
hiding in the fundamentals of what
you're doing if there's one principle
behind all martial arts improvement I
would say it's the analysis and the
removal of what's unnecessary it's
obviously what every kind of biohacking
modality promises us a better way to do
things faster more efficient in less
time and so on or good technique is a
result of lack of refinement and more
energy is being used than is necessary
to complete a technique which is
consequently wasted this can be overcome
back correctly understanding one's
bodily mechanics this series will focus
on those concepts with regards to kick
in technique so you want to work towards
been able to execute your kicks with
maximum efficiency devastating power
while also being graceful and having
finesse hence the reason for me calling
my teaching and my brand optimal
technique it's this constant analysis
refinement and removing what's
unnecessary that allows the master of
any endeavor to perform effortlessly in
a way that the majority of people think
is impossible at its foundation this is
just an incredibly refined economical
nature
so the first concept that we're going to
discuss is a term I like to call the arc
of attack so this applies to any kicks
that are coming in from the side so like
a turning kick or a hook kick for
instance what you want to do with this
is obviously you've got your center line
down the middle and wherever your target
is striking this down that center line
you want to imagine an arc shape like
this which is where your kick is going
to travel across now people who aren't
very experienced with kicks and don't
really know what they're doing will have
a big wide arc and that's where they're
wasting all their energy because the
kick has to go fully across in life
whatever we do compounds over time and
by constantly practicing and drilling on
those basic concepts that's going to
have an effect and carry over into all
different areas of your training so take
a look at this example to see what I'm
talking about if you can see here I am
performing a standing and hook kick from
my lead leg now if you look at it
closely we've got the chamber the
extension point and then finally the
reach aim bur at the end which completes
the kick now this is roughly the shape
that the kick travels through on its
part with the three white dots
representing the different points now
this is what it would look like if it
traveled across a much wider arc and
this is where the energy is being wasted
the why did the arc of the kick the more
the leg has to do therefore wasting
energy and resulting in a slower kick
and the reason that's really important
is because then when you go to do say a
spin hook keep like I'm doing here then
the practice of having the short arc on
the prerequisite kick which was the
standard hook kick is gonna then
translate into this kick as well and how
that would work in Reverse is if you had
a very wide and loose arc on your normal
hook kick then you would also have a
very wide and loose spin hook kick so in
order to shorten the arc like this we
need to be aware of a few things
if you imagine here this is the point
where you're chambered kick extends
before you hit your target you travel
across through and hit the target and
then this point is where you reach aim
bur the kick back in kicking technique
should be precise and not labored the
legs are some of the largest muscles in
the body so we need to learn to control
them properly or they're just going to
SAP all of our energy so by focusing on
this we're not having to muscle through
and drag our legs through the technique
which will result in a slow kick with
lackluster power and almost as important
as energy conservation refining your arc
will serve to make your kicks more
invisible against it
as well as I mentioned before if you
have a big wide arc like this and you'll
having to drag your leg right through a
technique then your opponent's going to
see that coming a mile off it's like if
I was to throw a punch for instance for
this example if I swing a punch out like
this you're gonna see it coming a mile
off whereas if I'm nice and tight and
throw it in it's a lot harder to read so
if you've got a nice narrow arc it will
almost appear as if even though you're
doing a turning kick then it comes
straight towards your opponent and then
only travels across in a short motion
before it's returned back now our eyes
struggle to judge distances correctly in
front of us and we're not really able to
read that we're much better with
peripheral vision which is why we have
brake lights on our cars so this isn't
such an issue when you're executing
techniques to travel down a straight
line like a front kick or a side kick
for example but if you are unaware of
this and you're very wide when you are
throwing say a turning kick then even in
the ponent with the most limited
experience is going to be able to read
that a mile off by understanding and
working within your arc of attack you
can make it so that your side on kicking
techniques aren't visible until it's too
late
this is one of the reasons that Edson
Barboza was able to learn this
spectacular spin hook kick knockout if
you notice how tightly wrapped his body
is when he's spinning round his opponent
didn't even see it coming and just had
no chance and then combine that as well
if the opponent's moving forward it's
even harder to spot be mindful to take
this concept into your own training and
build up slowly at first so start slowly
practicing it slowly taking your body
exactly through the movement you want to
do and then when it comes to doing it
quickly hopefully it will be second
nature by then and you'll be able to
execute the technique exactly the same
[Music]
so a good way to drill this as mentioned
before is by practicing slowly I'm gonna
hold onto this ledge here this wall and
you want to you want to do this so that
you are taking care of your balance so
that you can completely give your
attention and focus to what you want to
drill into your muscles if you were
practicing this and you weren't holding
on to something for instance and you
were trying to kick your your balance
then you're not going to really be able
to focus on what you want so that's why
we do this firstly obviously ensure that
you're pivoting foot is in the correct
position or that's gonna mess you up
straightaway
make sure the pivoting before my heel is
facing completely towards the camera now
it's out at the minute but that's where
it is so that I can open my hips up
correctly and in terms of the arc then
for this I'm gonna show you a couple of
different demonstrations the way I kick
like this is I will have the chamber
position up here and out like I said
I'll try to extend the kick as close to
the target as I can so I want to bring
it out about here first doing a hook
kick for instance and I'll bring it
across the target and bring it back down
straight away so if I do that quickly it
will look like this and again and once
more now if you may see somebody less
experienced do this their kick is gonna
come out wider from here and then finish
more across there which is what I was
talking about using too much energy and
wasting time and being completely
readable as well so the way that would
look would be more like this would be
more wide lack of a chamber slow out of
control the body is falling down as
opposed to be a nice and tight
whippy and back in control and coming
down again another way to really help
this and boost it a little bit is to
practice the visualization technique
that I laid out in my previous video
visualization is really good for things
like teaching your body how you would
like it to move beforehand so I will put
a link in the description for that as
well what's up guys I want to hear from
martial eyes so that I can make my own
line material better please feel free to
send me an email at this address I'd
like to ask you a few questions if you
liked this video and found value in it
please subscribe to the Baniya and
follow me across all social media
platforms thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you next time